[Musique]
bienvenue à tous ceux n'y avait pas eu
de mal à trouver le premier sujet de
cette émission
bien évidemment la corée du nord est le
sommet trump kim qui s'est terminée ce
matin nos invités que vous allez
découvrir ont certainement un avis là
dessus
et bien sûr nous attendons vos questions
et vos commentaires sur le sujet nous
reviendrons en france aussi pour parler
de la politique sociale des manuels
macron cette fameuse jambe gauche qu'il
aurait tendance à oublier mais qu'ils
n'oublient pas complètement puisqu'il
doit prononcer un discours demain sur le
sujet pendant ce temps le sort des
migrants de l'aquarius restent floues ce
qui est sûr c'est que la question comme
il fallait s'y attendre n'a pas fini de
diviser les européens
dernier épisode en date le président
français qui critiquent sévèrement le
refus italien d'accueillir le bateau et
ses occupants
enfin nous continuerons de voyager en
russie où l'équipe de france est à
l'entraînement avant son premier match
samedi et nous voyagerons aussi dans nos
souvenirs ceux de 1998 c'était il ya
vingt ans bonjour bonjour à tous les
quatre bonjour xavier couture
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes conçu
vos dents vous connaissez parfaitement
la politique la communication le monde
du sport
vous êtes l'homme de la situation au
jour réglages et chef du service
politique de france inter et pour notre
plus grand plaisir un habitué de point
de vue le mardi bonjour renaud girard
vous êtes le chroniqueur international
du figaro nous sommes contents que vous
soyez là pour nous parler de l'accord
est des migrants d'ailleurs petite
question dans cours de vos reportages
vous êtes vous avez eu l'occasion
d'aller en corée du nord
jamais jamais demandé mais j'ai jamais
l'autorisation jamais eu l'autorisation
pourtant c'est un régime sympathique
inquiète connu sans doute
et bien merci aussi marc landré d'être
avec nous rédacteur en chef du service
économie france du figaro je ne suis pas
les noms et vous n'êtes pas parce qu'on
connaît un peu quand on suit point de
vue on sait que vous êtes allé en israël
au danemark et à la corée du nord lui
aussi a pas longtemps j'ai passé
quelques petites valide frontières ça ne
fait pas le savoir alors cette poignée
de main elle a duré 12 secondes selon
les observateurs les invitations à la
maison blanche et à pyonyang n'ont pas
tardé à être lancée le sommet a été
qualifiée de honnête et productif par le
président américain
mais sur quoi débouchera cette rencontre
que deviendra l'accord signé sur la d
nucléaire dénucléarisation dans quelques
mois quelques années
l'américain et le coréen le nord coréens
sont imprévisibles leurs intérêts ne
sont pas toujours convergents
on va voir tout cela mais avant je vous
propose d'écouter donald trump c'était
ce matin à singapour garantir qu après
vos questions vous allez vous asseoir
par exemple tout simplement essayer de
signer des accords c'est ce que
j'exprime toute ma vie mon travail
commence à désaccord gc lorsque mon
interlocuteur en face et précise renaud
virage
regardez attentivement le donald trump
vous êtes le spécialiste on l'a dit mais
dites-nous juste un mot déjà franchement
savent bluff cet accord ça vous vous
êtes surpris vous attendiez pas à ce que
ça tourne comme ça avant singapour à
chaud effectivement c'est un coup troc
n'est pas net rationnel dans les
relations internationales
il décide d'habitude dans les relations
internationales
on consulte on rassemble un petit
cénacle autour de soi et puis on fait la
décision est toujours un petit peu
collective lui c'est par pure intuition
un jour il dit tiens on va essayer ça et
c'est une sorte de monstre au sens
étymologique au sens latin des relations
internationales train pays un autre
monstre de foire de prodige de
au sens latin des relations atteint le
sol c'est kim jong-hun balle et sa marge
est ensemble et donc et donc c'est ainsi
que naquit alors si ça marche dire si il
ya des réalisations c'est à dire que si
il ya un début effectivement de
dénucléarisation de nouvelles ententes
entre le nord et la corée du nord et la
corée du sud si l'amérique au bout une
ambassade ou un bureau de représentation
à pyongyang
si la corée du nord peut refaire du
commerce avec le monde entier
eh bien on aura le saluer ce coup de
génie alors s'il arrive à tenir je pense
jusqu'aux élections de mi-mandat de
l'émetteur de ce qui arrive en novembre
où il s'agit de renouveler toute la
chambre des représentants et un tiers du
sénat
eh bien je pense que blair peut très
bien gagner 6000 tonnes il ya encore là
on disait qu'il allait une piste c est
destitué mais je pense qu'il peut très
bien les gagner sur trois messages
on entre plus aux états unis comme dans
un moulin ya là dessus et puis et puis
se succèdent renault ses pieds couture
déjà sur le ce que disent et rauno une
d'espèces d'alchimie improbable mais
entre ces deux hommes mais moi je n'ai
pas tout à fait la même analyse critique
de donald trump que celle qu'on entend
depuis son élection à savoir une sorte
d'être totalement imprévisible un peu
irrationnel et totalement fou c'est vrai
que sa communication est tout à fait
déstabilisante pour le monde auquel nous
appartement appartenant qui est un monde
médiatique
habitué à un système politique plus
policé mais je ne vois pas de
l'irrationalité quand on tire le trait
de la politique de de trump sur le
depuis qu'il a été élu certes il ya des
foucades de communication des tweets
invraisemblable une espèce de forme un
peu agressive voire pétaradante de dire
les choses mais sur la politique de fond
il est assez qu'on serrait constant où
il ya une forme de rationalité dans ce
qu'il pense qu'il veut obtenir
alors certes la corée dans cette affaire
sorte évidemment vainqueur la réalité
c'est que la dynastie kim voulait une
reconnaissance internationale
elle lui est offerte par trump qui lui a
un besoin de reconnaissance dont sont
sur son propre électorat avec les
élections de mid term qui arrivent et
avec l'idée que dans le fond déconnecter
un tout petit peu
l'accord est à la fois d'un projet
militaire dangereux et en même temps
peut-être de s'arranger pour que elles
se ressemblent un peu avec la corée du
sud sur le dos des chinois revoilà il ya
un jeu de plaques tectoniques qui est
assez complexe
je pense que tout ça sert l'intérêt les
intérêts des états unis sachant que pour
trump et da selaou vraiment sa politique
est constante
son seul intérêt c'est l'intérêt
américain le reste n'existe pas et pour
le coup il assume totalement
c'est le premier président des états
unis depuis 1945 qui soit nationaliste
au change pas du terme
elles ont cherché je souscris à ce que
dit xavier couture effectivement on a là
un président qui résonne en businessman
mais pour les intérêts américains dans
america first il ya ça il ya d'abord les
intérêts américains
sauf qu'au final dans ce à quoi on
assiste aujourd'hui je me lasse pas de
cette image quand même le la cravate
rouge de trump et le col mao de kim
jong-un
c'est historique effectivement mais là
donald trump est ce qu'il est le plus
fort dans cette relation bilatérale
c'est pas sûr il amène sur un plateau ce
que recherchait la dynastie des kim
c'est à dire cette reconnaissance à
l'international quarante ans quand même
depuis 40 ans les kim rêvait de pouvoir
s'asseoir d'égalité à égalité avec les
américains et les sud coréens qui vont
peut-être avoir peur derrière parce que
là ce que cherche team c'est à
déconnecter les américains de la corée
du sud a découplé finalement la relation
qui était jusque là depuis la guerre
froide entre corée du sud et états unis
donc il a fait un coup donald trump nous
parle d'un document qu'on ne voit pas il
y aura un teasing un feuilleton sur ce
document là qu'a été signés dont on ne
connaît pas le contenu on aime on n'a
pas vu le document on va voir les
signatures en revanche on voudrait qu'on
s'arrête un instant sur la graphologie
si on peut voir les signatures de donald
trump et du président nord-coréen
on les voit oui c'est des tweets et on
aimerait avoir un graphologue qui qu'ils
fassent un peu d'analystes
si ça vaut ce que ça vaut mais les le
contraste est saisissant l'un cris
l'autre l'autre est beaucoup plus way
rendra pas quoi et du sud sont inquiètes
parce que ces prises le président moon
qui a d'ailleurs été élu sur un mandat
de deux de discussions avec la corée du
nord
c'est lui qui a initié en fait ce sommet
puisque c'est en fait il a envoyé ses
représentants sont celles qu'on sait
national de sécurité à la maison blanche
et c'est quand donald trump a vu que ce
type était à la maison blanche irakien
mais je veux le voir comme la mène et
c'est là qu'il a dit ben finalement
passer ce message à kim jong hoon et je
veux bien discuter avec le leader de la
corée du nord
donc je ne crois pas en fait que la
corée le krach la corée du sud se
réjouit de cet accord du fait que la
tension baisse
et puis c'est un accord qui profitera en
premier a kid a lâché à la chine
j'aimerais qu'on attende un incident
marc landré qu'on lui donnait pas jeu
sur un point aussi que peut-être plus de
la forme est ce on le sait donald trump
est un businessman il le disait
d'ailleurs dans le sens nord qu'on a
passé moi c'est le deal que je passe je
j'ai des intuitions et je sais négocier
jeu quand on voit l empire qu'il a
réussi à construire dans l'immobilier
aux états unis et le fait qu'il ait
réussi à prendre la présidence des états
unis en comptant considéré par la classe
mondiale comme un guignol
effectivement au moins il a sens du
business il est le sens découvre ça
c'est sûr et au delà de ça je trouve que
ce qui moi je suis pas un expert des
relations internationales donc je ne
ferai pas de grandes théories sur la
tectonique des plaques entre la chine la
corée du sud et a rappelé tout en
revanche que trop votre voisin de gauche
la station jaurès pour nous il le fera
très bien entre tout le monde en
revanche moi ce que je trouve formidable
en tant que citoyen lambda c'est qu'on
avait quand même il ya trois mois de
monstres dans le monde qui parlait de la
taille des boutons nucléaire sur leurs
bureaux dont keys et moi j'ai pu
s'associer déçu et de pulvériser ta
planète
je trouve que le pack on a fait deux
géants en quelques mois de je vais te
mettre sur la gueule
je vais détruire je vais pulvériser d'un
côté et l'autre moi j'ai un plus gros
boutons toi à cette poignée de main
effectivement historique
alors après est-ce que ça sert là ce que
c'est assez à l'autre moi je crois que
pour l'instant
le monde entier parce qu'il ya une
espèce de décélération dans un monde qui
est hyper tumultueux qui est en crise
permanente de voir ces deux fous se
serrer la main
et ben moi je trouve ça même si mauvais
mariage de renault vira acquiesce à vous
prenez donc votre analyse doit être
lundi environ 16 je récuse l'idée que ce
soit deux fois dire qu'on nous avons une
lecture qui est une lecture de
communicants et parce qu'ils
communiquent de manière irrationnelle
ces deux individus sont considérés comme
des fous la réalité c'est qu'ils font la
démonstration qu'ils sont pas si fou que
ça une question renault parce que sur ce
plateau le 24 mai on venait de tomber
l'annoncent que le sommet était annulée
dans notre homme avait dit non
finalement ça n'aura pas lieu je ne veux
pas vous voir je suis très en colère
on peut dans quinze jours dire
finalement cet accord il vole en éclats
on remet les têtes deux des têtes
nucléaires et c'est reparti pour bien
sûr c'est un risque parce que d'abord il
ya tous les communicants qui peuvent
reprendre
dessus il y avait eu des communications
catastrophique notamment de john bolton
c'est le nouveau conseiller national
sécurité de tram qui avait dit que en
fait le destin de la corée du nord
c'était celle celui de la libye de
kadhafi alors évidemment les coréens du
nord s'était raidi donc on peut avoir
tous les accidents effectivement et
notamment des accidents provoqués par
des phrases malheureuses ça c'est tout à
fait possible
mais je pense que c'est quand même
l'intérêt de trump de montrer qu'il a
grand succès diplomatique parce qu'on
l'a tous dit son objectif c'est de
persuader le peuple américain qu'il est
le meilleur qu'il est meilleur que son
prédécesseur en tout cas qu obama et
qu'il est le meilleur
et puis c'est quand même l'intérêt de la
corée du nord qui est un pays à très
industrialisé mais qui en manquent n'a
pas accès aux grandes routes
commerciales mêmes routes commerciales
chinoises d'avoir l'abandon des
sanctions qui sont quand même très
sévère que les nations unies ont mis sur
la corée du nord et qu'ils avaient six
missions sont respectées en échange de
quoi c'est encore très flou cet achat va
être très difficile pour lui faisait
moins de renoncer à son assurance vie
qui est là et qui a été l'armé l'armé
nucléaire donc ça va être définitivement
bolton mais que dit bolton bolton il dit
à partager moment c'est satio il l'a
théorisé à partir du moment nous avons
retiré
l'arme nucléaire de de la deûle à la
corée du nord
il se passera la même chose ce que nous
avons fait en libye on attend du moment
où en irak à partir du moment où il n'y
a plus la menace qui pèse sur l'humanité
nous détruirons le régime c'est bien ça
la terre une bonne note et la
destruction des régimes mais là il ya eu
des garanties données par jacky décision
de la gym cerveau bolton appartient à
cette vieille génération des néo
conservateurs notamment ceux qui étaient
autour de jardel et bouge les
néoconservateurs c'est ce qu'ils pensent
qu' il faut imposer la démocratie
démocratie par la guerre c'est qu'ils
considèrent que les idées de démocratie
de justice sont plus importantes que les
idées de paix contrairement au réalisme
considère que la paix c'est plus
important que le reste mais trump n'est
pas dans cette vision là comme des en
macro non plus c'est à dire que tous les
deux ont dit publiquement qu'il ne
voulait pas entrer dans la changer
entrez dans la souveraineté des états
qu'ils respectaient la souveraineté des
états et qui ne voulaient pas il avait
renoncé au changement de régime par la
force intéressant très rapidement c'est
que vous avez donc un triomphe du
bilatéralisme clairement et chacun a
donné des gages à son peuple
tri mais avant de venir emmanuel magne
l'acompte donald trump en s'asseyant sur
le g7 est aussi alors c'est juste la
dramatisation de la volonté de
effectivement de faire un coup d'éclat
ou g7 pour mieux briller à singapour
avec c'est une bonne interprétation de
la façon dont ça s'est passé au g7 à
nous et je crois pas il ya eu des
analyses est un peu compliqué comme ça
mais comme on dit un terme anglais phare
fait jetons dit un peu moi je crois
qu'il faut pas prendre des villes est
dérivée seconde faut prendre les choses
telles qu'elles sont trump
il a son caractère il considère que
notamment l'allemagne triche c'est à
dire que l'allemagne se fait payer sa
défense par les états unis un excédent
commercial extraordinaire avec des états
unis et que c'est injuste et qui veut
casser ça après voilà et donc c'était
mal parti
ce g7 et puis ensuite il ya eu le
discours devant la conférence de presse
peut-être un peu discourtoise du jeu
s'exprime alors que l'autre est parti ça
suffit à faire cesser voilà mais il ya
il ya vraiment il ya vraiment des
vraiment des différences
la première différence qui est baisse de
7 par exemple c'est que trump appuyés
par l'état lit d'ailleurs ont voulu
réadmettre c'était du moins l'avis de
bonnes idées russie vernette la russie
dans le g7 les autres ont dit non donc
voilà je fais tout ce sont les hawks qui
dans quelques quelques réactions de nos
internautes
alors que dans ce geste est là pour la
première fois c'était avant n'a fait de
la politique intérieure
quelques réactions diam qui s'interroge
quel enseignement tirez vous de cette
nouvelle alliance qui se profile entre
les états unis et la péninsule coréenne
n'a tenté d'y répondre je pense qu'on
pourra pas être plus complet pour le
moment béatrice trump a des chances de
réussir tant mieux ben qu'est ce qui a
fait basculer kim
il ya quelques mois à hawaii était en
alerte nucléaire avec insultes
réciproque on l'a évoqué aussi béatrice
toujours trump est un vrai patriote
contrairement à ses prédécesseurs
jce trump se désolidarise de l'europe et
se fait de nouveaux amis
on va et venir et 350 très mettre enfin
un terme à la guerre froide c'est son
avis alors à propos des nouveaux amis je
voudrais qu'on écoute l'ancien ministre
des affaires étrangères hubert védrine
il était ce matin sur europe 1 il parle
de la chine qu'on a évoqué également
je lisais en venant un papier excellent
de renaud girard dans le figaro de ce
matin qui dit et je pense comme lui que
le vrai problème du rock ainsi que sont
incapables d'avoir une pensée
stratégique s'il était stratégie qui se
concentrerait sur le fait ne pas faire
basculer la russie du côté chinois et
avec la chine
donner un contenu à ce qu'a dit le
président mettront qui était très juste
à pékin il faudrait que ce soit
symétrique les routes de la soie may cry
dissymétrie par rapport à la chine tout
en travaillant avec elle c'est un effort
énorme
alors après ce compliment bien méritée
renault juste un point bref c'est
difficile mais sur la chine
effectivement la gagnante de ce sommet
ah oui la chine a toujours voulu elle a
toujours dit d'ailleurs qu' il y ait un
dialogue direct entre l'amérique et la
corée du nord parce que toute la
diplomatie des deux dernières décennies
c'était de faire en sorte que la chine
fasse pression sur la corée du nord pour
qu'elle change de politique et les
chinois n'ont cessé les diplomates
sinon de nous dire en fait vous croyez
qu'on est très proche de la côte nord
mais non ils ne nous et qu'on n'a pas
forcément la seule chose dont il rêve
c'est de parler en tête à tête aux
américains
donc ils sont arrivés à leurs fins les
chinois il ya eu ce sommet et puis c'est
évident que il avait très peur d'une
déstabilisation de la corée du nord
avoir un problème gigantesque de
réfugiés ils n'ont plus et puis c'était
évident que comme c'est là
grandes puissances commerciales
asiatiques si le commerce reprend avec
la corée du nord commerciaux est
interrompue aujourd'hui par des
sanctions de l'onu la génération les
bénéficiaires et puis euh euh ça les
arrange qui est dénucléarisation de la
péninsule coréenne ce que c'est cette
saisie contre la chine
et ils préfèrent avoir une région
pacifique dénucléarisé on a déjà le
japon qui est dénucléarisé il reste bien
sûr la flotte américaine
mais eux le plus la vie il peut être
dénucléarisé le mieux la chine se porte
on voit que vous avez l'habitude de
prononcer le mot dénucléarisé là la
question twitter qu'on vous a posé c'est
l'intitulé pensez vous que kim jong
respectera l'accord donné
dénucléarisation gelé n'est pas le
l'habitude de renault gérard signé avec
donald trump et de vous êtes 39% à
répondre que oui
c'est la question qui était posée sur le
figaro.fr on passe à la politique
sociale maintenant des manuels macron
alors emmanuel macron doit-il muscler sa
jambe gauche
c'était le titre de l'interview que vous
adonner marc landré l'ancien ministre du
travail mme myriam el khomri s'était
publié ce samedi dans le figaro
l'ex ministre n'est pas la seule a
estimé que la politique sociale est un
peu la laisser pour compte de cette
première année de présidence macron dans
la majorité certains partagent ce point
de vue comme on va le voir demain au
congrès de la mutualité française
emmanuel macron doit prononcer un
discours stratégique ce sont les termes
de l'elysée sur le sujet on va voir tout
ça mais je vous propose d'écouter
d'abord brigitte bourguignon lé député
la république en marche et elle et
préside la commission des affaires
sociales à l'assemblée nationale c'est
un peu l'ailé gauche de la république en
marche on écoute je crois que la basket
gauche est en train de prendre forme et
que le projet social donc nous portons
et moi je me mets dedans je me mets pas
à l'extérieur au contraire
arrive vraiment maintenant alors marque
déjà la place gars les gens avec les
propos parce que je veux vous dire que
quand nos fenêtres pas du tout ce
discours là là bas cette gauche déjà
c'est bizarre comme terme
oui c'est au moins ça fait ça fait
reprendre les mots de communication ça
doit être ça change vite le mot basket
avait été utilisé par par nicolas
demorand beurre ou pas d'accord alors ça
y est c'est grand virage social ou pas
du tout je crois que emmanuel macron n'a
aucune intention de modifier le sens de
sa politique
simplement comme tous ces dirigeants a
compris il considère que si ça se passe
mal c'est qu'il n'a pas suffisamment
bien expliqué et qu'il n'a pas
suffisamment de relais pour faire
comprendre à l'opinion le sens de la
politique qu'il conduit
donc il va simplement faire comme disait
nicolas sakozy c'est tous des cons il
faut que fasse le boulot moi même il
valait fall boulot lui-même dire qu'il
va aller à la mutualité comme fond on
fait tous ses prédécesseurs pour
expliquer le sens de sa politique
sociale
comme il n'y a que des incapables au
gouvernement qui sont sont pas en mesure
d'expliquer ce qu'il fait lui en a le
goût de relais à l'assemblée lui au
moins quand il parle ça sera clair au
programme je suis pas sûr que ça change
fondamentalement la chose cela dit
on est dans un monde c'est une guerre de
perspectives puisque quoiqu'il fasse il
restera le président des riches pour une
grande majorité des français
il a aboli sf hm moitié en le
transformant en impôts soit là de nature
vierge immobilière donc ça c'est son
crime de lèse majesté il assume jusqu'au
bout il augmenter la csg pour les
retraités et les retraités pour lui
aisée ça commence à 1200 euros par mois
de pension
c'est un deuxième crime de lèse majesté
quoi qu'ils fassent derrière il aura
beau faire du social il aura beau
remettre des sous dans la machine ça
marchera pas ceci dit et en plus
pourquoi je dis ça parce que tout le
monde l'a oublié mais si on prend le
budget 2010 8 donc le premier et le seul
pour l'instant fait sous mandature
macron quels sont les crédits qui ont le
plus augmenté en pourcentage les
dernières les crédits sociaux
ça veut dire que l'argent là où il l'a
mis l'année dernière c'est sur le
minimum vieillesse c'est sur la prime
d'activité c'est sur les locations
adultes handicapés c'est à dire c'est là
où lui considère qu'il doit mettre en
oeuvre la politique sociale le problème
c'est que ça ne percute pas ça ne rime
pas parce qu'il n'a pas de relais et
parce que ça ne se voit pas par rapport
à l' isf qui reste le dire elle
l'imprimatur de son de son magistère
une lecture différente de la version par
rapport à ce que disait marc sait si
vous voulez prendre des baffes à
l'elysée vous leur dites alors la jambe
gauche voulait muscler et là on vous dit
à sortait la journaliste du vieux monde
vous n'avez rien compris à la pensée
complexe de macron ya plus de gauche il
ya plus de droite ya l'efficacité c'est
l'efficacité
c'est le parti de l'efficacité donc en
fait si vous leur dites vous irez qui
libre demain pour à montpellier la
mutualité ben vous n'avez rien compris
il ya pas d y avait pas d équilibre donc
ya pas d équilibre voilà ceseda méthode
coué ça c'est les mots owned un porte
parole de l'elysée bruno roger-petit qui
vous engueuler quand quand vous lui
parlez de jambe gauche ou de jambe
droite
sauf qu'en réalité moi je vais vous dire
qu'il ya une inflexion tacite en tout
cas dans cette séquence juin mi juin à
mi juillet qui s'ouvre avec montpellier
avec ce congrès de la mutualité bien
évidemment parce que là il va pouvoir
dérouler le reste à charge 0 sur les
problèmes oculaires et dentaire d'ici à
2022 il va aussi redonner le sens
évidemment de sa politique sociale se re
so ciel se re socialiste il non il n'est
pas socialiste emmanuel macron et puis
vous avez en même moment à l'assemblée
le protégé de la loi pénicaud sur la
formation professionnelle qui suit son
cours et pas seulement ça le plan pauvre
début juillet d un plan mobile ou
séquences le plan qualité qui apporte
des moyens notamment dans les zones
rurales désenclaver pour rénover les
routes
il est reporté aux ennemis de les
limites de tout ça c'est pas quand même
aussi le les dépenses publiques à
falloir menace même ce même ça c'est à
ses fils ou parce que vous avez le
dommage où les cet angle mais cap 22 ne
sera pas publié le fameux rapport
anxiogène que toulon grain il est
saucissonné ministère par ministère
personnes en vue d'ensemble de cette
oeuvre
et cette voix là ne sera pas publié il y
aura des arbitrages edouard philippe
d'un coup et peut-être ensuite une
publication au long cours et perlé de ce
rapport cap 22 ça aussi c'est une
manière de faire baisser la température
c'est sûr que là la dépense publique
reste une obsession à l'elysée ça c'est
une certitude et évidemment la jambe
gauche
pour autant qu'elles puissent être
aujourd'hui musclée au grand dam de
effectivement début de l'ag retirer on
en parle
elle ne pourra être musclé que de
manière ciblée et par des jeux de passes
communicants mais la réalité c'est
effectivement comédie et marque
il ya un certain nombre de mesures qui
ont été prises mais comme etienne
mougeotte à l'époque où je travaillais
avec lui plus vrai que la vérité à
l'apparence mon mieux et donc il y à un
moment où la lame un certain nombre de
mesures
que ce soit le rapport borloo qui est
mis sous le tapis
que ce soit mais effectivement ces
mesures sur les appels qui ont fait
parler
il ya un certain nombre lisf évidemment
toutes ces mesures donnent le sentiment
non pas qu'il est le président des
riches mais pour citer joseph macé
scaron à qui j'ai entendu of sa part de
dire ça il dit c'est pas le président
des riches l'insup eric c'est le
président de ceux qui veulent devenir
riche et donc c'était assez comme
analyse parce qu'en fait
c'est bien la réalité d'un changement de
société auquel mayall macron 40 ans veut
essayer de faire profiter la france
aujourd'hui ce pays vieux pays lui
raisonnement vieille attitude que vous
avez d'observation d'un monde qui avance
et sur lequel vous ne comprenez rien
néanmoins j'écoutais brigitte
bourguignon ce matin avec attention
honnêtement vous avez passé ce tour et
d'interviews où elle est solidaire avec
avec le gouvernement la réalité c'est
que si vous écoutez l'interview dans sa
danse est que ça merci je vais voir ce
que j'ai fait elle est elle est
solidaire du bout des lèvres on se
rencontre dans toute l'interview elle
extrêmement mal à l'aise avec cette idée
d'une jambe gauche atrophiée
actuellement dans la politique
gouvernementale
renault juste un mot tu voyais un
sondage et l'ap qui disent 67 % des
sympathisants de gauche se défient des
manuels macron alors que 55% je crois
des anciens électeurs de françois fillon
adhère à sa politique
quelles conclusions en tirer quel est
votre point de l'être le problème c'est
que la france est un pays où depuis
giscard d'ailleurs on a introduit
progressivement le socialisme et puis ça
s'est beaucoup accéléré avec mitterrand
cédera donc si elle devenue le seul pays
socialistes en fait le grand seule
grosse usine ce moment de rang mais du
monde en fait varier corée du nord cuba
va s'abaisser tapis on a dix points de
plus de dépenses publiques que
l'allemagne au moins une mais il
m'arrive de halle en allemagne mais
pendant ma voiture palau j'en sais c'est
pas l'impression que les allemands sont
plus mal traités que nous quoi j'ai
appris j'ai l'impression que c'est la
même chose que les hôpitaux c'est la
même chose les routes c'est la même
chose qui est à peu près la même chose
l'éducation etc c'est pas plus mal qu'en
france mais on dépense 10 points plus
alors qu'on peut continuer à dépenser
l'argent qu'on emprunte écoles
connaissent à six instruments inc est-ce
que ce qui vous ce qu'il faut combien
comprendre c'est con à 2000 milliards de
dettes parce que tous ces cadeaux l'apl
pourquoi est-ce que le goût
l'état finance le logement des gens on
peut on pourrait aussi voilà que le
figaro mme finance mon logement pourquoi
pas voilà pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi
est-ce-que alors on est dans un pays
socialiste et j'ai l'impression de
critiquer la droite n'a jamais osé nos
sorties la droite n'est jamais en fait
oser y compris nicolas sarkozy il n'a
pas vraiment oser sortir du socialisme
macron il dit peut-être que il faudra
quand même qu'on sorte du socialiste
parce qu'on a deux mille milliards de
dettes et que peut-être un jour on n'a
pas respecté nos engagements européens
des 3% de déficit maximum et peut-être
qu'un jour on n'acceptera plus de nous
prêter donc la france fera faillite
et alors moi je trouve moi je trouve
qu'il va un petit peu lentement et cette
dame qui parlait ce matin mais je ne
peux pas écouter madame bourguignon donc
parce que gisèle figaro je préfère dire
les chagos et rien de mieux que france
inter je n'ai pas que je n'ai pas écouté
donc cette dame bourguignons mais son
c'est ça sa basket sociale elle la
finance comment est ce qu'elle peut nous
le dire
est ce que il faut qu'on aille vers 60
points de pib pour financer les dépenses
publiques
c'est quoi le communiste français
qu'elle nous le dise ça m'a répondu ah
non girard sur le point notamment le
manuel macron sort la france du
socialisme je souscris pas ça parce que
comparer les modèles allemands et
français les mettre sur un pied
d'égalité il ya tellement critères à
regarder dans le détail je suis pas sûr
qu'on puisse dire que des pauvres seront
traités de la même manière en allemagne
qu'en france je suis pas sûr qu'il y ait
autant de travail en hyper pauvres en
france comme en allemagne il n'y a pas
la cogestion je suis d'accord avec les
syndicats mais l'école et commence par
exemple à 6 ans en allemagne et une
prise en charge en france historique
c'est lié à l'après guerre de la petite
enfance
d'ailleurs mme emmanuel macron veut
ouvrir rendre obligatoire à l'école
maternelle pour tous de trois ans des
trois ans donc forcément le coût social
n'est pas le même à la fin et les
étudiants meilleurs que nous - beaucoup
ces trois années supplémentaires par
l'état c'est quoi le résultat
l'egypte en train de vous faire un
procès
mentalement mais moins bon que les
étudiants france conséquence des
résultats c'est que la démographie
allemandes allaient plutôt à l'école
militaire qu'ils ont moins en moins
d'actifs et qui sont obligés d'importer
énormément d'immigration pour pouvoir
maintenir un niveau de vie identique
alors que nous on a moins d'immigration
relativement on a une démographie site
est très porteuse et qu'au final un
petit peu moins ces derniers oui mais
c'était la même agence
j'entends cet argumentaire jeu ce que je
déplore c'est que on oppose
effectivement une forme de
dysfonctionnements dans les démocraties
européennes qui ont elles des dépenses
publiques plus faible que la nôtre
évidemment à un système qui est lui très
protecteur de craie la société dans son
sens le plus large du terme
la réalité c'est tout de même qu'alors
il a été prévu une régionalisation qui a
eu lieu puis ensuite une loi de réforme
de l'état qui ont été mis en place
du bout des lèvres la réalité c'est que
l'état ne sait pas se réformer que
l'état n'a pas su découpler ce qui est
donné à la région de ses clés données ou
centrale que sur un certain nombre de
dépenses publiques
on pourrait faire passer des audits pour
permettre de passer avec le même
résultat une fille née de sa fille vous
immunise du budget s'est par ailleurs
des audits soient laissés pas publique
la seule chose c'est que l'organisation
n'avait rien sur l'a7 qu'il faut prendre
des décisions politiques bien voilà
c'est sur la base d'un audit décider
mais je dis pas là jeudi pal inverse et
la cour des comptes un bras et chaque
année avec son rapport sur un certain
nombre de dysfonctionnements et
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait rien coûté 1
million fonctionner en plus lorsqu'on a
fait après la loi de décentralisation
moi je suis désolé mais j'ai connu les
départements avant 1982 il n'était pas
plus mal administré qu'ils ne le sont
aujourd'hui
oui les paris n'était pas le propre plus
sales qui ne l'est aujourd'hui peut-être
plus ponctuellement aux gens les plus
propres jouets voilà donc on a un
million de fonctionnant plus
il ya un vrai problème il ya un vrai
problème il faut dire les choses comme
elles sont depuis le départ de raymond
barre qui était le dernier homme d'état
français
ce pays n'est plus géré ses eaux que
aucune boîte n'aurait pu continuer comme
ça mais depuis le vent il y à voter
nombre vers le pays n'est pas gérée
aulas mouvoir la vue sur air france la
vue sur d'autres entreprises publiques
l'état n'est pas le meilleur
actionnaires dénoncent personnes disons
que en disant cela on sait tous que
l'état est un actionnaire assez
déplorable lorsqu'il a une entreprise à
gérer dit il est très inquiétant de se
dire que si des tapas très bonne action
naires il est peut-être pas le très bon
actionnaire de lui même c'est ça moi ki
moon qui me gêne lorsque le rsa les
contre exemples récents la sécu c'est
vrai elle va traiter cela s'est couché
oui mais c'est la cdu à une bonne
gestion est ce que c'est la croissance
grâce à la croissance mais s'il vous
plaît on va pas entamer on n'entame pas
le débat sur la sécurité sociale on l'a
dit c'est la croissance qui améliore sa
situation
je vous donne la réponse alors vous
allez peut-être surpris la question et
twitter emmanuel macron doit-il
renforcer sa politique sociale et bien
vous êtes 70% à dire que oui présentée
et je donne quelques réactions johan
c'est vrai que la politique sociale du
ps a fait ses preuves
trois points de suspension anti mac
brigitte bourguignon aurait dû rester au
ps
et ça sera tout pour ce thème si vous le
voulez bien
aujourd'hui on va passer à la situation
de l'aquarius c'est donc finalement à
valence en espagne que de vrais débats
qu'un parent devrait débarquer les
migrants après plusieurs péripéties ces
dernières 48 heures les refus de
l'italie et de malte d'ouvrir leurs
ports à ce bateau l'offre des
nationalistes corses et les divisions
des européens dernière division date les
propos d' emmanuel macron ce matin en
conseil des ministres il s'en est pris à
l'italie c'est ce qu'a déclaré le porte
parole du gouvernement benjamin griveaux
à l'issue du conseil des ministres
on écoute dans cette crise l'italie
s'est substituée aux autorités libyennes
puisque le navire aquarius était dans
les eaux internationales les eaux
libyennes pardon et elle s'est
substituée sans aller jusqu'au bout de
la démarche
et il ya là la preuve d'une forme de
cynisme et d'une part d'irresponsabilité
du gouvernement italien face à cette
situation humanitaire draps
tic renault cette fois ça semble
vraiment craquer de toutes parts sur la
question des migrants
parce qu'avant déjà il y avait là
maintenant il tally qui refusent
l'aquarius c'est pas le symbole que
finalement cette question est insoluble
en fait si vous voulez où ils s'écrasent
ne joue pas c'est à dire que c'est une
question très grave c'est la grande
question c'est le grand sujet du moment
en fait emmanuel macron devrait se
préoccuper de deux choses en france
l'important c'est le problème des
migrants et le problème évidemment de
l'emploi qui selon moi ne peut ne peut
se faire qu on est dans les entreprises
et les entrepreneurs en tentant d'en
france vient alors sur les migrants et
bien la politique n'a jamais été
européenne puisque nous avons eu la
décision stratégique la plus importante
des dernières années qui était prise par
angela merkel sans consultation de ses
partenaires europe
c'est à dire que quand elle a dit qu'ils
avaient huit cent mille place au chaud
en allemagne avec l'école gratuite les
soins gratuits 1500 euros de différentes
prestations etc
elle a fait bouger il faut bien
comprendre ça des dizaines et des
dizaines et des dizaines de millions de
miséreux
je connais bien l'afghanistan je connais
bien la baignoire et ai pas seulement ou
même le je connais bien le pakistan il
ya beaucoup de pacs est ce un pays en
paix le pakistan qui évidemment ont
envie d'aller dans cet eldorado
voilà donc est là mais elle n'a pas du
tout demander elle réagi séquence
émotion elle une photo d'un jeune âge et
l as absolument pas fait de la stratégie
elle sait pas alors on est on est face à
une à une démographie c'est une urgence
à gérer en explosion démographique
non mais c'est de prendre le il jamais
on est en 1018 démographique en afrique
avec une poussée formidable vers
l'eldorado européen et avec tout un
trafic c'est-à-dire un système où les
barbes ou les les passeurs c'est voulu
j'aimerais utilisent les ong ou la
marine
lien pour faire leur boulot parce qu'ils
prennent 3000 $ par part par migrants
mais ils ont pas envie de les
transporter jusqu'aux côtes italiennes
alors ils appellent à 12 milles des
côtes libera jeu coûte que coûte et
comment ça fait maintenant six ans
maintenant je pense que je pense que le
patou je pense que ce bateau moi je
pense qu'il faut appliquer le droit de
la mer louis fournier le bateau en état
les naufragés par vettel en libye 12 ai
parlé à l'obliger à les emballer dans le
port ce bateau aquarius il faut aller
dans le port de tripoli est débarqué
c'est parce que la surprise en attendant
on met des gens on sait en libye ça se
passe pas très bien pour les migrants ça
nourrit son talent et poésie sont allés
alors il son réseau bienvenue en libye
donc il faut appliquer le droit de la
mer c'est à dire que vous avez des
naufragés mais si on va pas les laisser
se noyer
et donc on les ramène d'où ils ont
embarqué
donc on les ramène en libye voilà il ya
élection de la crise pas mais demain
qu'on pose problème vous avez un
l'elysée silencieux pendant quasiment 24
heures il faut que jean guy talamoni
gilles simeoni qui savez la politique
eux-mêmes intérieure corses
il faut que ces deux là se manifeste
pour que en conseil des ministres grivot
et la question et répondait qu'est ce
que dit griveaux grosso modo c'est
presque comme si l'insultait les
italiens qui viennent de voter en
d'ailleurs je vous intéresse il se
dévoue appelle ceux des doigts président
du conseil italien vient de réagir aux
propos de rapporter par benjamin
griveaux et d'emmanuel macron il dit
finalement c'est l'hypocrisie tout ça on
n'a pas de leçons d' hypocrisie à
recevoir des dons de la france mais
c'est ce que ça va être
qu'est ce que dit emmanuel macron
derrière on peut aider maintenant
l'espagne et pedro sanchez qui accueille
le propose d'accueillir le bateau sur
les à valence on est pardon mais
pourquoi emmanuel macron ne s'en saisit
pas il a peur des sondages qui montrent
que droite extrême droite voire au delà
il ya une
une trouille qui monte de l'arrivée
d'invasion des migrants en france
pourquoi il prend pas à bras le corps ce
dossier au moment où sa majorité lui
reproche d'avoir été peut-être un peu
trop dure sur la loisy l'immigration il
récidive y lire des cassures dans sa
majorité
vous n'imaginez pas comme la réunion de
groupe ce matin de la république en
marche était houleuse à l'assemblée
on a retrouvé tous ceux qui s'étaient
opposés loisy l'immigration qui
attendait là le geste peut-être
présidentielle humains pour gérer une
urgence il n'est pas venu
et au lieu de ça on dit aux italiens bah
c'est pas bien mais oui mais et si on
prenait aussi la nôtre part du problème
alors on va justement écouter xavier
couture je vous donne la balle dans un
instant voudrais juste qu'on écoute pour
compléter ce que dit zahia elle ose
gabriela talent porte parole de la
république en marche était ce matin sur
public sénat
la ligne du gouvernement italien est à
vomir c'est inadmissible de faire de la
petite politique avec des vies humaines
comme ce qui est fait en ce moment qu'on
pose la question de la ligne migratoire
de l'union européenne qu'on pose la
question de des solutions qui peuvent
être trouvées au niveau européen pour
mieux réguler mieux prendre en charge
ces flux migratoires évidemment et la
france le fait emmanuel macron le fait
depuis maintenant un an je n'imagine pas
que la france ne participe pas à trouver
une solution humanitaire pour ce bateau
c'est évidemment sur sur la réalité du
problème avec une réaction émotionnelle
avec fonctionnelle est tout à fait assez
grotesque venant d'un pays qui n'a
absolument rien fait la france ayant été
pour moi absente du sujet si depuis
quand même quelques années alors je ne
reviens pas sur la décision de nommer à
merkel qui était une décision avant tout
liées à l'emploi en allemagne en fait il
y avait besoin de main d'oeuvre on a dit
tout à l'heure on a parlé tout à l'heure
ce problème démographique qui
aujourd'hui occupent l'allemagne mais on
n'a pas parlé l'accord de dublin qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui pour pouvoir se
faire régulariser il faut que le migrant
réussissent à faire sa demande de
naturalisation dans le pays où ils
arrivent
quels sont les pays où arrivent les
migrants l'italie et la grèce on a
abandonné
l'italie et la grèce la france en
priorité on les a abandonnés évidemment
en les abandonnant qu'est ce qu'on a
fait on a fait que ces pays qui n'ont
pas d'immigration traditionnellement pas
eu la problématique nous avons eu avec
la décolonisation dont ils ne
connaissent pas ça
il doit arriver c'est flou évidemment ça
a amené le gouvernement actuel en italie
cette alliance et team coast elle est
bien que se passe-t-il et il s'applique
ce qu'ils honnissent auto fait lire là
dessus on en a marre d'être les pigeons
de l'europe et d'être obligé
d'accueillir au nom de l'accord de
dublin
l'ensemble des migrants mais qu'est ce
qui va se passer derrière et c'est là où
moi je ne suis pas d'accord avec renault
il y à 450 à 500 millions de migrants
qui se prépare à envahir l'europe
si on ne fait pas quelque chose qui
permette un de les maintenir chez eux 2
d'organiser l'accueil
pour ce qui de toute manière vont venir
qu'est ce qu'on va faire on va couler
les bateaux
vous allez raccompagné des dizaines et
des dizaines de bateaux à en libye ça
n'a pas de sens il faut qu'on arrive à
trouver une solution une solution
européenne
2 que les pays européens dont la france
mais par tino c'est cet égoïsme qui est
un égoïsme court termiste à courte vue
et trois qu'on soit en capacité de
régler à peu près la problématique des
pages suis tout à fait d'accord pour
aider les pays africains effectivement à
fixer ces jeunes populations africaines
ces jeunes mâles africains qui viennent
qui viennent d'ailleurs qui sont des
classes moyens et ce qu'il faut réunir
ses 3000 l'hérault pour enseigner le
passage et qui en fait qu'est ce qui
compte en fait on on prend ces
ressources humains parce que c'était
type débrouillards qui viennent s'était
acquis avons réuni de l'argent on est
donc évidemment il faut les viser alors
comment faire mais il fallait d'abord
pas faire cet appel d'air parce que
souvent d'ailleurs c'est pas ils sont
pas si heureux que ça dans l'eldorado et
les gens qui les accueille en italie il
n'y a pas il n'ya pas aussi du bonheur à
les accueillir donc en fait c'est une
politique qui est mauvaise des deux
côtés est ce qu'on pourrait faire si on
pourrait faire des choses on pourrait
dès a par exemple à stabiliser la libye
et par exemple a aidé la libye même à
protéger sa frontière méridionale c'est
à dire sur le désert et j'étais
d'ailleurs l'autre jour j'ai rencontré
un homme politique libyen qui veut
lancer
deux forums quatrième voie libyenne et
m'expliquer quand fait personne mais que
qu' on peut très bien la libye peut très
bien sécuriser sa frontière
s'il a dû faisant là c'est de cette
région a pour empêcher pour pour propos
pour couper l'appel d'air mais je pense
que il faut je pense quand même qu'il
faut à un moment donné arrêter cet appel
d extraordinaire parce que ça va mal
finir on a énormément évolué sur la
question entre le moment où angela
merkel en 2015 10 à lui est à bercy
mines et de l'économie est dit il à fait
licite quasiment veut pour son humanité
il va mieux le val suis pas par contre
prend une position inverse à matignon
est aujourd'hui emmanuel macron et sur
duval
concernant le fait de ne pas être
quelques quelques réactions sur ce sujet
béatrice qui nous dit létale il fait
face aux problèmes toute seule depuis
longtemps les français sont une fois de
plus arrogant elle rejoint peu ce que
vous disiez xavier couture isométrique
les états lien complète aussi les
italiens ont accueilli des centaines de
milliers de personnes et la france
combien anti mac l'europe n'est plus en
mesure de gérer une crise pourquoi
croyez vous que les anti système ont
tant de succès on l'a évoqué
effectivement avec le résultat des
élections italienne aucun pays nos abris
qui n'en veut pas et tous accusent
l'italie complète encore il aux
métriques et marie-claude je trouve que
les ministres la république en marche
condamne bien facilement le gouvernement
italien à qui on demande beaucoup et la
réponse à notre question posée là encore
sur twitter selon vous est-ce à l'europe
de gérer la crise ni corps at war dont
la cua russe est un des exemples est
bien ma foi c'est assez partagés 51 % de
oui on va provisoirement quitté ce sujet
en tout cas pour aujourd'hui je vous
propose de parler un peu football alors
football pourquoi et bien à ma foi parce
que eh bien c'est bientôt j - 4 c'est du
moins quatre oui pour la france le match
c'est samedi son premier match de la
coupe du monde en russie et il y a vingt
ans tout juste c'était le coup d'envoi
de la coupe du monde en france et un
mois plus tard le 12 juillet les trois
buts de la victoire pour zidane et ses
coéquipiers alors ce soir à nanterre les
anciens rejoue le match
la france s'apprête à vivre à l'heure du
foot pendant un mois doit elle aussi
mettre les pendules 20 ans en arrière on
va en débattre
mais d'abord vous propose d'écouter
eddine zidane ça a été historique
historique puisque puisqu'on l'a fait
qu'une fois et d'ailleurs on sait la
difficulté que l'on a de gagner en
cohésion dans la gagné qu'une seule fois
un pour ce qui est du foot donc c'est
tout le mal qu'on souhaite à 7 à cette
jeune équipe dont qui va qui va jouer
cette coupe du monde la russie pour les
cas probables il ya du talent là dedans
il ya de la folie de dieu de la vie
parce que parce qu une compétition comme
celle-là ça transcende aussi donc ça
vous et sourire marc landré je sais que
vous êtes plus passionnés par le le
tennis que par le foot je me suis très
nostalgique de 88 de la victoire de
carlos moya roland garros nadal comme
laquelle gagné onze fois le type de
relation
j'aurais pas dû alors le foot
zidane ça me fait sourire c'est quoi
c'est le côté aventure un peu complexe
de la princesse idée dit oui parce que
la limite il peut dire que c'est
historique c'est unique en vérité quand
on n'a gagné qu'une fois c'est nathalie
face et voilà donc il ya des mots pour
ça vous allez regarder le match des
légendes ce soir les uns les autres et
il passerait à huit tf1 garde la plus
basse à tf1 non mais oui le vin pas là
tous pris 20 ans et cette année c'est
pas le même sport
alors on a tout donné on a tous pris
l'on bafoue tna tous prix moi j'ai pas
la télévision mais j'adore le rugby est
non alors à 10h30 café non parce que je
trouve que le télé le rugby la
télévision c'est fantastique c'est un
jeu stratégique et je travaille jusqu'à
ce que la wii hd vous étiez où vous
étiez où le 12 juillet jour de la
victoire de la victoire française donc
j'atterris c'est à nice pour passer
quelques vacances c'était l'été je crois
et où 1,8 m
et voilà c'était et j'ai regardé quand
même le match j'ai vu les trois matchs
contre le brésil il me souviens même que
c est contre le brésil et le bruit j'ai
participé à la liesse générale
mais le sport qui m'intéresse le sport
que je lis dans le figaro c'est en clair
et je n'ai pas beaucoup de chance en ce
moment parce que c'est vraiment on est
vraiment nul c'est un conte points de
suite par les all blacks après la
nostalgie vrai l'étape de 2,98 oui une
nostalgie bien établies ce qui
effectivement d'abord comme le disait
tout à l'heure il est il une victoire
unique et historique mais sur le côté la
france ça va vite un temps alors y avait
la france de la réconciliation il avait
chirac qui avait du mal à prononcer le
nom des joueurs enfin on a tellement
dense et moi j'étais au stade pascal
épaule était directeur de l'antenne de
tf1 qui retransmettait cette finale donc
il était avec j'avais amené pour être
une sorte de consultant de luxe le même
des jarres depardieu qui était drôle
comme tout et qui hurlait trezeguet
trezeguet 14 et triste 14 est restée il
éclaté de rire qui serait que cette
blague 13 et 14 entre s'était fait 13
chérif je faisais beaucoup rire et donc
ils souvenir de ge est une forme de
nostalgie parce que on a toujours des
toits nostalgique par rapport aux grands
moments qu'on a vécus un temps
auparavant c'est une évidence
maintenant j'ai vraiment je me refuse à
la nostalgie en matière de sport c'est
sait rien de plus qu'à ce pied que de
revenir alors j'ai le plus grand respect
pour le match qui devait avoir lieu ce
soir mais honnêtement ce qui m'intéresse
c'est ce que va faire cette jeune équipe
est-ce que et d'ailleurs comment ça
président des chiens qui étaient sur le
terrain en 98 va-t-il les mener à la
victoire
je l'espère je rappelle simplement que
en règle générale quand le pays n'est
pas extraordinairement puissants en
matière de football via le brésil
l'allemagne souvent le pays organisateur
a une bonne chance de vaincre
il se trouve que là la russie elle l
aime vraiment pas dans les favoris dans
le jeu est très ouvert pour une fois il
saleh ça la france a possibilité de nous
surprendre et de fer avec deschamps un
vrai cadeau
vingt ans après à une société qui sera
bien heureuse de redescendre dans la rue
des bersaults bleu blanc rouge pour
terminer sur cette note les français
apparemment de 90 sont plus en forme que
les brésiliens qui ont été incapables de
réunir une équipe et de jouer vingt ans
après il ya un danger à faire trop de
vétérans là c'est que le gars comme
l'ombre de la statue du commandeur sur
les jeunes un moment donné parce que là
on célèbre des champions du monde et
deux essais anciens intervenants des
socialistes aujourd'hui comment voulait
la quitter si vous avez le mal le
l'ancêtre qui pèse sur vous mais moi je
leur madre delonge avant la course et
dans un long ballon vous vous trouvez
que
je un peu trouble a dit dan il aurait
pas de troubles dit simplement que sa
salle maurice a nourri un voyage je
pense pas que ce soit volontaire de sa
part mais il se trouve que ça na le
timing il a choisi le savait qu'il y
avait du monde et pas cher c'est aux
conséquences moi j'étais en voyage
linguistique à londres tout seul à
défendre mon pays
souvenirs de 80 des anglais évidemment
anti frogs dans le pub et j'étais tout
seul à faire oui super on a gagné dans
mon petit coin de peur d'aller vous
coucher après celle d'emc coucher et
c'était très calme à londres y avait
aucune fête pour les français n'ont
évidemment black blanc beur la gauche
plurielle ils ont applaudi des français
c'est en ce match sais pas si vous vous
souvenez la coupe du monde de rugby on
commence à perdre contre les all blacks
etc et qu'ensuite et un jeu de génie
avec michalak est extraordinaire guerre
du boeuf avec les anglais et là tout
d'un coup c'était en angleterre dans le
stade tout le stade donc plus d'anglais
se lève et se met à chanter ses missions
est terminée vous avez réussi à la
ramener au rugby alors qu'on était censé
parler vous vous êtes très fort renaud
girard
merci beaucoup à tous les quatre et
rendez vous demain avec guillaume
roquette pour un nouveau point de vue
[Musique]